the book is called the smooth hops and
bad bounces from the inside world of the
acclaimed Los Angeles Dodgers general
manager the 10th general manager in the
history of the Los Angeles Dodgers he is
currently the senior advisor to the
president of the Los Angeles Dodgers
what a great title for Ned Colletti who
is here on the Rich Eisen show good to
see you ned thank you it's good to be
there so let's get into it right here
and and now you were the Dodgers manager
general manager from Oh 5 to 2014 so so
much of what we're seeing now seeds
planted during those periods of time
what did you see first time you laid
eyes on Cody Bellinger would be one well
probably his senior year I went to high
school in Phoenix and was always slicked
around the bag he could play first base
in the big leagues probably right then
and there a little bit experienced
really great athlete but had a great
mind for the game and as a young kid to
be able to slow a game down and to play
it almost in snapshots instead of a
movie type thing we watch a game we
watch like in a movie right guys like
that Bellinger Seeger the Great's of the
game especially the young guys that can
do it they break it down almost in
snapshots and they can slow the game
down kind of analyze it pitch by pitch
you had that ability right away dad
played in a big league so he had a
little bit of Nadeem I remember clay
from his cup of coffee a couple years
with the New York Yankees again Ned
Colletti the general manager for many
seasons for the LA Dodgers here in the
Honda inside a report on the Rich Eisen
show how can you look at a high school
kid and say that kid can play in the
major leagues well he was he was
actually easy to see and project because
of the athleticism and how his mind
worked you get to see that the kid
understood it better than anybody else
on the field better than anybody else I
saw him play against he was like a man
against boys even though the birth
certificate was the same yeah and but
you could say that okay this kid who's
currently maybe taking AP geometry he
can actually play in the major leagues
yaz ravine
well I knew it's gonna be a big league
player that I think he was gonna set the
National League home run record rights
for a rookie I can't tell you I knew
that was coming but that the ability to
play and the ability to be athletic and
also play another position because he
had to play the outfield too but then it
was there's just a matter of time and
acclimating him at different situations
we also put him up a year ahead of time
every year he ended up playing with
older kids older young players
professional players
season they kind of test him and to kind
of keep the competition and a peak
higher than him so he could reach it he
didn't he didn't play what guys have
equal ability he played with guys for a
while of more ability mmm more maturity
that he had to kind of grow into and he
did and Seeger was another one those
guys almost identical singers got
another the way his mind works is unique
for his age you'll have a conversation
with him at 18 19 20 year old you
thought you'd be talking to somebody 30
years old because he just has a presence
to him they're very similar in that
they're both left-handed they're both
obviously great young players but they
both slow to game down and in my career
I've seen great ones slow the game down
a Maddux a Bond's Manny Ramirez guys
like that cranky but these kids at that
age you need to have that ability
obviously you need more than just
generational talents at certain
positions in order to win in a major
league baseball level it's sustain it
and then championship quality thus you
need guys like Justin Turner you need
those guys what did you see in him that
other teams did not we had a we have
three veteran utility guys a year before
we had Nick Punto Jerry Hairston Jr and
skip Schumacher and Jerry was gonna
retire Nichkhun and skip were looking
for two-year deals I love these guys but
not enough to give him a two-year deal
and so they went elsewhere and I was
looking for somebody who was younger who
had some offensive ability to him and JT
always was a decent offensive player
offensive player defensively he was a
little bit average I would say at that
point in time and we waited for the
market to clear a little bit and then we
went out and we signed him and to his
credit he came here he had a major
league deal offer from us and then we
did a physical and his knee which he had
operate on a couple years ago flunked
the physical so I went back to him and I
said I still want you but I want you on
a minor-league deal not a major-league
deal and it's a tough thing for a big
league player to accept I says are you
healthy he says I feel great I said okay
the x-ray says otherwise
if you believe in yourself come here
look at my roster you're the guy you're
gonna be an extra guy here any-any took
the deal makes the team ends up now is
it a crossroads of his career too
because the Mets to let him go and he
started with Baltimore he starts to work
in the wintertime like crazy and he
became not only one of the best
in the game but one of the best
defenders in the game that he can hit
and is hit as well as he has a little
bit of a surprise that his defenses come
as long as it as far as it has that's a
tremendous surprise but this kid works
baseball players are sometimes made in
season most of them are made in the
offseason when everybody else is kind of
taking it easy this kid worked works
every offseason now works relentlessly
to become the player he's been would you
say something like Justin Turner to use
the phrase of one of your predecessors
that that's the residue of design being
lucky with him right yeah some extent no
doubt no doubt yeah because I mean where
the hell did he come from Yeah right
I mean I mean you just described
obviously the hard work that goes into
it and I don't mean to denigrate that at
all but no I mean don't you think the
Mets fans see them and of course
everybody loves to dump on much fans in
that regard that they could have had him
but they didn't really have the guy that
the Dodgers have that toughest thing
they have in in this business yeah is
patience especially in baseball because
you play it every day and so you're
evaluating it every day and it's tough
in a major market in New York LA a lot
of them to have the patience you're
gonna need in order to wait for somebody
to mature and the wait for somebody to
kind of figure it out it took that much
time for JT to figure it out until this
year we could say the same thing about
yasiel plays it's about to say that it's
taken him a while and you have to have
the patience and it's tough cuz you look
at it every day and if you everyday
vehicle boy I'm really frustrated with
this the play or this or that and you
let that building in five days you know
five days in the in Major League
Baseball's like five weeks in the NFL
you got five weeks of evaluation crammed
into five days so you have to be patient
with it and fans don't have to be
patient with anything but if you're
sitting in that chair
you better be patient with it the Honda
inside a rapport with Ned Colletti
former general manager now the senior
advisor to the president the Los Angeles
Dodgers when tweet was sent down
Oklahoma City last year I thought that
was it honestly I thought that this was
a designated for assignment and then
BOOM over but what was going on in in
did you come close did the team come
close to sending packing last year I
don't think so you know my robot is not
what it was I can't exactly what that is
but I can tell you that it was it was
time it was time for him really to be
held accountable and I applaud Andrew
Friedman for doing it and Dave Roberts
your successor and the manager yeah to
really hold him accountable because he
needed that change and you see what it
is today and it's a different player
stellastot tremendous talent but to
focus and and the pressure on him is
different it's less he was a three four
five here in their lineup and pitching
would eat him up guys who could really
spin a breaking ball ate him up
then suddenly he goes off to the side he
goes to the minor leagues his name is
all over trade rumors all this is going
on out suddenly he comes into camp and
he's not the three four or five hitter
he's got to make the team then he's
gonna play right field now you have a
right fielder who is 30 25 to 30 home
runs drives in 70 plus plays Gold Glove
right field and he hits eighth you know
many teams would take that everybody
everybody would take that but that's
what he's been able to do and I give
Dave Roberts a lot of credit for it and
to staff the coaching staff cos beta
worked with him and they stayed the
course but they made him accountable too
so Ned Colletti again the book is the
smooth hops and bad bounces from the
inside world of the acclaimed Los
Angeles Dodgers general manager we had
Bob Costas on in the first hour I said
what makes the Dodger so good and he
mentioned some of the guys that we've
already spoke but he's like he got
Kershaw at the top
he got Janssen in the back why did you
look at chance and say let's try and
make him into a reliever here how did
that process go back one simple thing he
couldn't hit and if he's watching he's
gonna be he's gonna be agitated with me
because I actually set up publicly he
had a great arm and he had good mind for
the position because that that's a tough
but that's the manager on the field that
position and he can and he knew it and
he's why so many become absolutely and
and he you know so he had oh he had a
feel for it and we were coming up to a
crucial time on his on his clock so to
speak in that he had to be put on the
roster and I thought if anybody else is
watching this guy's arm they may be
thinking the same thing we're thinking
and I would always tell my player
development people every spring we'd
have meetings I'd say okay remember
be on the lookout for a young player
that we've got here that's kind of maybe
hit the wall and this isn't going any
further in that position but he may have
a caring tour to a tool or two that can
really be a big-league thing this guy's
arm was that how is how is my thought
was that and they came to me in like
late April D John Watson and he says you
know you talk about this all the time
what about Kenley as a reliever I says
let's go so he talked to Kevin Lee first
and Kevin he says I want no part of it
and I went to Kelly and Kelly says I'm a
catcher I'm gonna catch in the big
leagues I said I don't see it and I says
I gotta put shot in my I'm gonna give
you it's my job to give you as good a
chance to get to the big leagues as
possible and that's what I see and he
kind of begrudging Lee did it and we put
him on the roster with only 12 innings
of like a ball pitching under his belt
but we believed in what he was gonna do
and in the process of doing it and we
had great staff that was gonna really
kind of find to it because it's not just
throwing a ball over the plate it's
holding runners on its fielding your
position it's understanding that the
throw a strike is great but you have to
throw an effective strike and then as
time went on he started to develop the
cutter and the slider was always
something he wouldn't do I had many
conversations with him his first year as
a reliever where where we debated I
guess debate would be a kind word to say
we debated what to do and how to do it
you know debated but he's turned out to
be the as good a closer Ezra's you look
at his numbers Center in a shorter
window than Mariano Rivera but if you
look at his numbers compared to Mariano
Rivera's and if he's able to sustain it
for a long period of time like Rivera
did he's right there well now that he's
been paid as he come up to say thanks to
you yeah he did yeah I get that once in
a while look at you I get there once a
while I get a text message that they
should being tough on me yeah that's
great yeah Ned Colletti here in the
Honda insider report again it's brought
to you by the Honda Odyssey the
available magic slide seats in the Honda
vaca it's never been easier to help keep
the peace or clean up when your kids get
a little bit too out of hand so be sure
to visit your local Honda dealer today
we come back in 60 seconds I want to ask
you harder hearts who the Dodgers are
rooting for today in in Washington DC
the first time you laid on Clayton
Kershaw and what the hell the spin rate
can tell
okay I want more than Ned Colletti right
here on the Richards and show back in 60
seconds
he's now a TV analyst here for the
Dodgers in Sports Net Los Angeles his
new book the big chair is available in
bookstores and online near you the
former general manager of the LA Dodgers
Ned Colletti here on the show heart of
hearts deep down Dave Roberts sitting
there by himself
Andrew Friedman your successor sitting
there by himself who they rootin for
today do you think they're rooting for
whether they're rooting for a long game
mm-hmm they're rooting to have as many
pictures on either side in the game no
doubt that's what they root for I don't
think they root for one team or another
come on they don't think they'd imagine
I ask you that who did the Dodgers
matchup better against it's tough to say
they would have a easy time against the
defending world champion you got
Strasburg and Scherzer to power arms and
the postseason that usually plays very
well but the way this series is gone
there's been so much wear and tear after
the season on that staff yes and today
we'll add to that I think it doesn't
matter who the Dodgers are gonna play I
think the Dodgers going through it with
a huge advantage okay
Vergara gainst either one doesn't matter
it doesn't matter it doesn't mean you
can't you can't pick who you want to
play anyway I did that 35 years ago and
that you will do that well I would think
I said I'd rather play this team than
that team and next thing I know we got
beat sucks and I'm not picking teams
you're out of that you're out my oneth
that's it right now let's talk to the
American League auto-ship series if I
could give you Ned Colletti one guy to
start a team with Aaron judge or Jose
Altuve they're both the same age Wow who
would you choose to start a team with
Altuve I love L to it I'm not there's a
lot to love with with judge too don't
get me wrong I just love what Altuve
does all over the game all different
things that he's got the ability to
change the game so many different ways
judge may have that in time judge's way
to change the game now is a hit at 450
feet but Altuve just the way he plays
and the leadership he has and the
maturity that he plays with he is uh
he's one of my favorite players to watch
well the the the distance the judge has
been having a problem with lately is 60
feet six inches yeah and so what are the
Yankees do with a guy who just struck
out a record number of times sitting
there in the two hole no matter
obviously how valuable he is what are
they
with him in that lineup do you think
heading into the series with the eyes
they have to try and calm his mind down
a little bit because it's only gonna get
tougher because when you're a hitter you
find out where your holes are in your
swing this time of year because you're
gonna get that seem to get exploited
time and time again and I think it's
it's a matter of him
you can adjust a little bit at this time
of year but there's so much behind you
already that it's tough to really change
course athletically but you have to
think about it a little bit not too much
you got to you got to measure how much
you try to switch but I think that that
he's gonna have to probably calm his
mind down a little bit because game goes
fast and guys start picking it up and
guys start moving faster than then it's
probably healthy for their performance I
think calm him down you got a great
manager and joking up somebody I've
known since he was 21 years old and and
I think calming him down get him in a
peaceful spot where he doesn't feel the
need to change a game every time he
swings the bat it's probably a positive
for him but this time of year you find
out what you can and can't do Ned
Colletti former Dodgers general manager
here in studio what do you think
Cashman's thinking today when he sees
Gregorius who he stated traded Shane
Green for in a three-way trade blossom
in the way that he's doing Todd Frazier
he picks up with Dave Robertson with
Kain Lee - we didn't even use Girardi
went straight for six out save with
Chapman last night but he picked up
Robertson and Frazier in as in a
mid-season trade with Frazier with a
huge at-bat prior to the huge at-bat by
yes Gardner last night and Robertson
bridging from CC to Chapman what it what
does a general manager feel the day
after something like that you're glad
you made the phone calls you're glad you
did what you did I've known cash in a
long time Cash's got a pocket full of
World Series rings I don't know that
he's ever done as good a job as he's
done this year really this team I think
is a year ahead of schedule I don't
think anybody expected them to be there
think about being with the Yankees think
about planning Yankee Stadium in that
market and kind of playing with the
houses money at this point in time who
expected this they have zero pressure on
of all the teams that are going to be
left after tonight all have far more
pressure on them than the Yankees and
the Yankees can put more pressure on
anybody and their stadium and their fan
base than any team they are in a very
unique position
I think cash has done a great job and
when you
pieces like that you had a Frazer really
maybe maybe hoping you're gonna get
three or four iconic at-bats
at best that can change the game change
this series is this time of year one
pitch can write history for somebody and
I think that that's what you're looking
for
and you're looking for that one time
where you know you see his name called
you see him come out of the dugout to do
this to do that or he's in the lineup
whoever it may be that's what you do it
for yeah and they in the they didn't
even use the players that they traded
Andrew Miller and Chapman for last year
they still have those kids oh yeah I
went through the pipeline oh yeah for
the future what's going on right yeah
for him to do what he did and in that
market as you know that's that's not an
easy place to say we're gonna rebuild it
yeah you know what you know but that
that's what they've done and it been
around the fly and here they are
a couple more minutes with former Dodger
GM Ned Colletti I gave you trout Harper
who do you start a franchise with one of
the two oh boy that's tough that's why I
asked us John Harper would you you only
get one give me another one they're kind
of dead even oh yeah I mean they're both
they're both young players you know
trout is magnificent he's magnificent is
his is DiMaggio I mean he's one of those
guys that's like that and Harper I don't
even know how good Harper's gonna be it
Harper maybe there's a child is as good
as trout's gonna be that's I'll say it
that way he he is what he is which is
terrific Harper I still think that we
don't really know how good he could be I
think there's still another level for
him nobody saying something all right
what the hell is spin right tell me why
stuff sir so do you believe in this
stuff I think it's something that I
still go the old school of I watch and I
need to know who the person is I need to
know who the soul of the player is who's
inside the uniform I look at it's been
rate exit velocity things like that it
can tell you a little bit of a story but
it doesn't it doesn't tell me and you
know I did invent re-entry velocity
what would have an awkward astrophysics
like this passed I was doing the doing
TV you know down the street with the
Dodgers Network and I said we ought to
keep track of how faster throwing a ball
in the outfield how much velocity is the
outfield the throw to a base on yasiel
Puig certainly was a guy that would get
this so I've invented that it's not
quite copyrighted yep it adds to the to
the show it adds to the game to talk
about spin rate and exit velocity this
and that I just cared the ball went over
the fence or not
are you a dinosaur in that regard maybe
who cares I'm just trying to determine
if analytics has really benefited the
game I think it has I think it I think
it has its place and I think it does
have great value my career really
started to take off because I used to do
analytics by hand this goes back 35
years ago one of my first managers and
one of my first GM's was Jimmy Frey who
was a coach for Earl Weaver and Earl
Weaver used to use matchups he used to
use how two guys perform close and late
runners in scoring position home road
day night but she didn't have any
service that would keep this for you so
you had to do it by hand so when Jimmy
Frey comes to manager Cubs in 1984 he
asked me if I could do this but all the
cub guys and so we did it and we did it
by hand so I see the value of it there's
no doubt I'm probably 52 48 52 I want to
see who it is I want to learn who the
people are 48 is ok show me the trends
show me the rates show me predict the
future based on a numerical analysis I
can buy into that but I still want to
know who's inside the universe and in
terms of Earl Weaver I mean the fact
that you could sit here and say with the
way the game is today right that
somebody's strategy of playing for the
three-run home run would be cutting-edge
right I mean look at today's game he's
playing everybody's playing for the 9
run yes oh yeah right now oh yeah it's
strikeout a home run and that was that
back - it was Weaver that was the
strategy
oh yeah don't punch somebody oh yeah
don't play small Paul played for the big
inning then people met you know people
didn't agree with that and now know
baby in his prime right now my god what
would he think he writing books you'd be
doing movies he'd be talking about exit
velocity maybe not my favorite my
favorite YouTube video is him getting
the gate and uh forget what what year
was where he gets thrown out by by an
UMP and it they're both miked up and my
favorite part of the video is that we're
showing it right now on the screen you
could see in the old memorial stadium
scoreboard it's the top of the first the
top of the first
and it's basically nine minutes into the
game and he says he's gonna go to the
Hall of Fame one day and the UMP says
back to him what are you go in the Hall
of Fame for F&I World Series
I miss guys like there any guys like
that anymore not anymore
I don't think so maybe I'm one here or
there but they VM used to be loaded with
them and some of the guys I had a chance
to learn from like Dallas Green was six
foot six and tough as nails beautiful
heart
Don Zimmer house with Zim for many many
years oh what a beauty well you too man
that this is the first time you've been
here I hope it's the first time many
I've really enjoyed this yet I'll stop
the u2 right back here at you go check
out the big chair get it read it great
read the smooth hops and bad bounces
from the inside world the acclaimed Los
Angeles Dodgers general manager Ned
Colletti the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app don't have any memory
on your phone let's start to delete some
of those slo-mo videos you have and you
know which ones I'm talking about